Continuing in al-Wajeez
the book of purification
and listing the author now
is going to list for us with evidence
the
various types of najasa, the various
types of filth.
Those things which are deemed najis
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in the Quran
or in the Sunnah of the prophet
salallahu alayhi wasallam.
And it's important that
all of the following is built on the
understanding
that we discussed yesterday morning and
the morning before with respect to the
way that this chapter is going to be
founded.
That
filth
when we say something is filthy, it's a
very specific meaning.
Doesn't just mean unclean or unsightly
or
ungodly.
It means that something is
positively
impure essentially.
It is inherently impure.
And this inherent impurity
is something that
has a ruling in the Quran and Sunnah.
And a person,
his salah, his
hasanat and sayyiat will by extension be
or directly impacted by these things
which are
considered najis, these things which are
considered filthy.
The first and second
things on this list
which are considered to be
filthy.
Right?
Are
urine and feces of the human being.
Human beings urine or feces.
This
is something which is
at the top of the list, not because it
is most filthy. It is at the top of the
list because it is most common.
Because these two types of filth
are arguably the most
the most commonly encountered and
the most
the things which a person may encounter
the most, the things which are most
common, the things which affect
each of us the most. Because it is
something that affects our body. we
use the restroom, we relieve ourselves,
and so we are
exposed to these two things with a much
higher frequency.
So, they top the list.
Now, filth
is on three different levels
as we will come to learn.
We have that which is intensely filthy.
Okay?
Then that which is filthy.
And then that which is mildly filthy.
So, we have intensely filthy, extreme
filth.
That which is filthy, and that which is
mildly filthy.
And the reason we make this distinction
is how we go about purifying these
things.
So, as we'll see
intensely filthy
is
the
saliva of a dog.
And many scholars place on that also any
part of a swine, any part of a pig.
Why?
Because in order to purify this, it must
be washed seven times
and once with
some kind of cleaning agent or
in the opinion of the majority
must be washed one time one of these
seven times with dirt.
Right?
The second is that which is filthy, and
that is what you would wash until it is
gone.
Yarhamukallah. That's what you would
wash until it is gone.
And then third, that which is mildly
filthy.
And
that
you do not necessarily have to wash, you
can spray and dilute while it's on the
garment itself.
[Arabic recitation]
when we
get to the chapters regarding how we
clean filth,
because
there are chapters in the book of books
of filth which discuss how to clean
filth.
Because
filth has been
not only outlined by the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam, but it has
also been
explained to us how to go about
cleaning it. What is considered to be
enough cleaning?
Right?
Likewise, we will get to the various
degrees of filth. What is important to
know that filth
is of different intensities with the
scholars of filth.
Now,
the list is in no particular order. The
list that the author is going to bring
us is in no particular order, or it is
in the order of
com- common commonality.
That which is most commonplace, that
which we are most likely to come in
contact with.
He will begin with that. So, the first
two that he mentions is urine and feces
of the human being, of the human being.
Okay? Whether he be Muslim or
non-Muslim, some scholars have made a
distinction. The correct opinion, there
is no distinction. Whether he be Muslim
or non-Muslim, these things are
inherently filthy.
[Silence]
When actually called a
[Arabic recitation]
to feces. However,
it is
actually the place where a person
relieves himself.
This is referred to as gha'it because al
gha'it in the Arabic language is a place
that is
of low elevation.
Why the place of low elevation? Because
people would go there to relieve
themselves. They're out of sight. They'd
go there, they'd be
you know, in a valley or somewhere and
they would be out of
people's natural plane of sight.
So, because it's the place that a person
goes to always to relieve themselves, it
becomes synonymous with
the
act and it becomes synonymous with
what is
done or what is commonly found in that
place.
But in this context,
is referring to feces.
Is urine.
Do you remember a month or two ago we
were discussing knowledge and the
difference between knowledge and
knowledge of knowledge, right? Or the
difference between knowledge and taqlid,
right?
And
we gave an example.
One of the examples was we all know
that feces is
is impure, that it is najis, right?
What's the evidence for that? Well, this
actually comes from a story
that happened with one of our
mashaikh many, many years ago
when they went to debate with
the
scholars of the Rafidah in their time.
I'll share that story with you tomorrow,
inshallah ta'ala, and we'll discuss the
evidence as well
[Arabic recitation]
All right, let's start now.
All right.